i really appreciate the very uh
introspective and honest answers and uh
this is i really can't wait for people
to see this i mean i'm having so much
fun i'm like
but we got we have we we're out of time
right now you guys you're way over your
time so we have to wrap this up but
thank you so much for coming we really
appreciate it and i hope you guys have a
great problem
[Music]
hi uh my name is greg alba and i'm john
humphrey and we're with the real rejects
thank you so much for taking the time to
speak with us we thought from the
trailers that this was going to be a
good show we were both surprised by just
how
it's yeah
it's awesome
i appreciate that we were so surprised
by like how real and authentic
everything felt for something that is
you know it's star wars yeah and the the
sentiment we kept echoing while we were
watching it was every time a character
is introduced including yours especially
yours you can always feel the history of
the character right away so i'm really
curious what was the process in
developing the backstory in the history
approaching this role did you mainly
work with tony gilroy did you do any
work with diego luna directly or was
this all just you creating memories on
your own and then bringing it to the
camera to play with i think there's
different elements of it
truthfully i think talking to tony was i
think number one also you know i spoke
to diego multiple times and we sort of
started to create
little scenarios and then the set the
set had something that is kind of
unexplainable and i'll tell you why it
was a city it was a real city it was
seven blocks it was huge and i was able
to explore my character's day-to-day
life right i was able to explore sort of
where she would go to oh that's where
casting would sort of jump up and come
down or whatever and and oh this is what
happened here or this is whatever
happened here that's so cool you could
build memories but yeah you could build
memories and be like oh this is where
she goes have us a drink after work you
know and and and then i would walk in
and i would open drawers and everything
that you wanted
to be in that drawer was in that drawer
i was like how are they so specific it
was filmable 360. and it gave this
freedom i spend more time in ferrix than
i did in my own home in london so
there's something about being a ferixion
there's something from being from ferrix
there's a camaraderie there's an even
exchange that happens even just being
there it does something to you it really
does so that sort of helped
helped and helped a lot and then you
have a great script in front of you that
that that is really easy to play with
you have diego who is so moldable on
screen and and it was just fun it was we
had space to have fun and leave things a
little open and close certain ones i had
a blast
yeah i mean you get the the impression
that like you get to do some real acting
and actual scene work and play around on
on a star wars show which is like
something you don't often get to really
say that often so yeah it's actually
really it's really refreshing it's
really refreshing john please well yeah
and stepping into a world that has so
much lore and such a fan expectation and
you're taking on the role of sort of
this you know the badass brooding female
lead which has become kind of tropified
and yet you know seeing this role of
yours and several of the other roles it
seems like you're good at embodying
these characters without ever feeling
like that's the note you're going for so
i mean where is all that is that in your
mind at all when you're approaching
something like this you know the both
the outside perspective of fans and then
just the perspective of like character
tropes like where is all that in your
process yes you know i i have an issue
with toughness i don't consider bix to
be tough i really consider her to be
strong and with strongness and and with
strength their strongness listen to me
with strength there's there's so many
different complexities that come into
that right there's a vulnerability that
really comes into play in order to be
really strong there's a vulnerable
aspect to the character that has to be
alive in order for her to be bright
right
yes it feels like a bigger challenge
because it is like this you know i'm i'm
this woman but in order for her to be
brave she needs to be able to put people
in front of herself and and that you
need to start sort of showing even from
the beginning and what i like about
biggs is that she's always shifting as
the world is shifting around her she's
kind of
shifting right you see her at the
beginning and she's so in charge of her
environment so in charge of this is my
cell yard i i run this
show i'm the boss and as soon as she
makes a decision of helping cassian and
things start getting out of her hands
and she starts shifting you know and and
kind of molding to what is around her
and by the end of episode three you
almost mourned the bix that you met in
episode one it's a very different
version of what then will become and you
know i think that heroines or or heroes
or or super strong characters or female
characters in a story like this or in
star wars i think there's so much more
and especially in this story you know
it's such about humans about the story
it's about a revolution it's about being
at a cusp of a revolution and no matter
how strong you are there's a lot of
stuff going on outside and and her moral
compass is sort of being questioned and
shifted in every direction do i become
part do i not do i stand do i fight do i
sit back
where do i stand where's my place and i
think that's kind of where pix is at and
that's
where my process sort of began and and
trying to make her as human as i
possibly could you know she has no
powers what i wanted to ask was while we
were watching it the main thing that
kept coming to my mind was you could
always feel the history of these
characters instantly it was like an
immediate impression so i'm curious with
you being a new character into this
world what was the process to creating
the history for because i don't want to
give any spoilers away for the audience
but what was the process for creating
the history for this character stepping
into this did you work with tony gilroy
a lot did you have to do a lot of star
wars lore exploration like what was what
was the actor process on this it was it
was it was pretty straightforward
actually a lot of it came from what tony
had written on the page
and then tony actually gave
at least me a lot of freedom to
investigate the the history of cyril and
i remember asking right at the very
beginning of chats about the character
in the project
i was like okay like five years uh where
like where did cyril end up man cause
i'm trying to plot him out oh cool
you know at the beginning like and tony
was like
uh well he could go here he could go
here haven't written it yet so i don't
know i was like
oh okay
and then it hit me later on that he was
really doing me a favor he was allowing
me to exist within the i don't know of
cyril who is
informed you know he's kind of like
pre-adolescent when you meet him he's
trying to figure he's in flux trying to
figure out who he is what he stands for
whether the risks that he wants to take
are worthwhile
so i then yeah chatted to him about what
maybe his his um upbringing was like
which became incredibly useful because
he wind up meeting his mother and
star wars actually goes incredibly
domestic and you get this
view and portrait of what created a
person like this you see that he
he comes from a place of lack and a
place of
real control and restriction and he's
applied that into his everyday life but
he's he's got no sense of
self
really and he's searching for that
validation and approval in the exterior
world
right so in his job but then also from
the empire and he sees that the empire
is this very easily navigated system
where if you do what they tell you to
and you do a good job and you take power
and control other away from other people
then you'll ascend the ranks and it's
much easier and more straightforward
than being a rebel like yeah that's true
like definitely dig
or something like it's um so yeah so
he's certainly lacking in certain
emotional capabilities at the same time
but um a lot of that yeah was was the
conversation between me and tony in no
hyperbolic way i believe you and the
rest of the unsolvable really succeeded
like the other sentiment we kept echoing
was it feels very human and everything
feels very gray and nothing grey quality
to it doesn't feel one dimensional at
all it feels like characters unfolding
amid circumstances rather than oh the
plot needs to go here you know like yeah
it feels very alive it was interesting
to me that i got like a sneak peek
behind someone that works for the empire
i i've always sort of judged them even
as a fan being like this is what this
person is i i have done that to a
character i've stamped that character as
something and especially with kyle's
character that you get to see him come
home yes
and you're like
oh this is what you're
go
this is oh
oh wait all of this started shifting and
then you start looking at it in a
different way or you're a cops really
trying to just do your job you know and
tony did a
really great job of
portraying that there is no good or bad
there's we all are living in this really
gray murky and i think every character
in in discovery and unfolding themselves
as this revolution is unfolding i really
appreciate the very uh introspective and
honest answers i would love to ask more
questions they're telling us to rap now
but i mean what i got to say is like
within the first few minutes of meeting
your character i i mean this in no
hyperbolic way i actually feel all that
history right away so seriously
congratulations on this and like you
were stan absolute standout so it's an
honor to speak with in time and and as a
character that's kind of presented at
the outset as an antagonist just really
quick like seldom have i latched on to
and sort of identified so much with the
character in that position and found
them so
despite the barriers so you're really
killing it yeah thank you for taking the
time to speak with us thank you thank
you so much appreciate it i mean i'm
having so much fun i'm like
but we got we have we we're out of time
right now you guys you're way over your
time so we have to wrap this up but
thank you so much for coming we really
appreciate it and i hope you guys have a
great problem
thank you very much